der tag am main bild reporter ist jetzt
in oldenburg schiller wie hat die stadt
denn die nachricht des unfalls
aufgenommen
ja ich befinde mich unmittelbar hier in
der nähe des wohnhauses der vierköpfigen
familie die bei diesem schrecklichen
unfall ums leben kam
ich konnte mit anwohnern sprechen sie
sind tief bestürzt sie sagten dass sie
das ist man immer wieder mal aus den
nachrichten von solchen unfällen hört
aber wenn es dann wirklich so nah an
einem ist dass die trauer gar nicht in
worte zu fassen ist der verstorbene mann
gürkan t
ein taxiunternehmer hier in oldenburg
sehr bekannt direkt an seinem haus
stehen auch noch weitere taxen taxis die
er im besitz hatte man muss dazu auch
sagen die nachricht hat aber auch nicht
nur die menschen in oldenburg erfasst
sondern ist es auch eine nachricht die
durch die gesamte deutsch türkische
community geht es sind vier ist
ferienzeit hier ist sind viele menschen
mit den autos in die türkei gereist und
solche nachrichten treffen die menschen
natürlich immer hart das kann ich mir
vorstellen auch diese familie war mit
dem auto in der türkei weiß man denn
warum die anwohner mir hier berichteten
waren sie in den ferien seit vier wochen
haben dort familie besucht das ist
natürlich die türkei ist natürlich nach
wie vor wald in deutsch türken das
urlaubsziel nummer eins man verbindet
urlaub damit dass man die verwandten
dort gesucht so war es auch bei der
familie t hier aus oldenburg sie warnen
hat ja im süden der türkei sollten
wahrscheinlich sogar schon ein paar tage
früher hier seien aber wollten dann das
opferfest das höchste islamische fest
dort in der türkei noch gemeinsam mit
der familie verbringen und waren jetzt
auf dem rückweg bis es dann zu diesem
schrecklichen unglück kam schnell alltag
alive aus oldenburg vielen dank für den
moment